[Music]
from marvel studios
the new logo is still going all right
i'll wait
from still going
[Music]
all right here it comes from
marv jeez
how long is this thing just cut it off
nobody has time for that
great now we're running behind it's thor
thor ragnarok
after the dark world marvel is back with
a radical new formula for the thor films
not making them suck yes
in an installment that trims all the
dead weight off the franchise
from his love interest sorry to hear
that jane dumps you to his homeland
to his friends you could name with a gun
to your head to his right eye
to his dad his hair dang even his hammer
they just trimmed all the weight off huh
it's like the whole franchise got on
hemsworth's steamed chicken diet
meet thor god of thunder who despite
being able to shoot lightning from his
hands spends most of the film getting
electrocuted
when thor's father luke skywalkers
himself into the afterlife
his sister hela goddess of pointy things
will return to claim the throne
in an epic family feud that will make
you wonder are we sure thor wasn't the
adopted one
put him next to hello loki and young
anthony hopkins and tell me he's not the
odd got out
thrill as indie comedy director taika
waititi
takes the reigns of a giant superhero
movie because when you're part of a 14
billion
global franchise ytf not now it's out
with the old and in with the jokes
behold my stuff
where boring exposition scenes get
tagged by jokes i will tower
over the mountains and bury my sword
deep in as well
hang on give it a second badass moments
get tagged by jokes you wanted to know
who i
am
[Music]
and even heartfelt emotional beats get
tagged by jokes
piss off ghosts yeah they overdo it
sometimes but this is a movie where an
orgy spaceship shoots fireworks over the
rainbow bridge where hulk fights a
zombie wolf
if you're mad at tries to make you laugh
too you're doing it wrong
follow thor's exile on sakaar a
collection of the galaxy's most colorful
gladiators
garbage and gold blues he's going to get
him first
and thrill as it turns into the closest
thing we'll get to a planet hulk movie
where bruce banner awakens to find he
spent the last two years of his life as
an enslaved killing machine
i've been hulk for two years what the
hell happened and take all of nine
minutes to get over it
you won revenge and i'm just undecided
together they'll team up with new
additions to the thorny verse like the
depressive alcoholic valkyrie
drinks a taika waititi made of rocks
crucible
and a mute bug with knives for arms and
they still have more personality than
the warriors three
dodge that bullet lady sif but don't
worry you still got it coming
enjoy the first marvel film where
everything actually looks like a classic
marvel comic book
that reminds us all though is a cosmic
viking created by nerds on acid in the
60s
it should look crazy with the best
bridge sequence since deadpool
the best two man laser fights in
starship troopers and the best vehicle
chase sequence where the hero jumps out
to take the bad guys down by hand
since all the other ones
[Music]
hey we found marvel's new sky beam yay
so get pumped for what's easily the best
thor movie
also the best hulk movie probably the
best doctor strange movie
the second best guardians movie and
shoot probably the best he-man movie
we're ever gonna get to that hopefully
taught marvel an important lesson
don't fire the weirdo embrace him
embrace that weirdo
happy thor dot gif i am lord yaya ya
actual jeff goldblum for the horde
ben tim someone get this woman an
untitled standalone movie
timed all the time they were able to get
idris l before she so thorny
george r r martin sure contractually
locked into a cameo
sorak the current state of the dc eu
could it be satan and thor the
4d experience coming summer 2020 to
disney's california adventure
flash thornton
look at these lies
[Music]
note to self before commissioning a
propaganda mural depicting my peaceful
rise to power
don't commission another mural depicting
the horrible horrible truth
and the oscar for best picture goes to
the fishbanging movie
so that's it huh we are just some kind
of justice league
my stripper name is sugar dust
wakanda forever
you